okay
oh [ __ ] welcome
back to your favorite podcasts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right y'all welcome back
[Music]
i'm singing mic broke oh [ __ ]
singing mic broke if you can believe
that so i got to get another singing mic
uh but in the meantime i just throw the
effects on this mic so it's the same
thing
i got my little device i need to use but
anyways i want to welcome you guys back
to another episode of riffing with
griffin
quarantine edition um you know
i don't know what day it is in
quarantine i got a grizzly beard going
on
we're doing the best we can i want to
thank everybody out there for continuing
to watch
and subscribe and share and all that you
really if you want to help me out
personally if you're wondering how i'm
doing you want to help me out that's all
you got to do
open up your browser open up the
the reference griffin playlist on
youtube and just let it play
with the ads look at the ads from me
you look at the ads that'll help me out
that cost you nothing
so i appreciate that but anyways i
appreciate you guys watching
we've had some good episodes i've been
doing a lot of skype calls i got a big
skype call on this episode
like 45 minutes long the sound's a
little wonky because it's still
difficult to get like the correct sound
because i got three guys
i'm talking to at the same time on this
particular podcast
just guys in my one of my crews that i'm
in the worst crew ever
that's what we call ourselves it's funny
because i'm in the worst fire team ever
as my video game grew and then this is
my comedian's actor crew worst crew ever
because we just are terrible like we we
don't call each other
you know like we'll be like doing stuff
and not let each other know but that's
actually mr craig robinson
from the office uh leonard robinson and
leonard robinson's a great actor
performer from uh he does a lot of
groundlings work and he's been on
if you saw his face he's been on so many
shows used to be on wilin out
so that's uh leonard robinson and uh
also the fantastic actor mr malcolm
barrett
who's been on my podcast before so i
have a great call with those guys so you
got to check that out
um but you know riverwood griffin is uh
here for you guys during these times
these troubled times it's actually
monday right now when you guys are
watching this
so we got some news about um what
how long much longer it might be i don't
know because i did this
before monday so i don't know what news
came out but i hope it was good news or
at least i hope it was our strategy
because at this point right now the only
good news we really want to hear is
they've discovered a vaccine and then
you know we could cure people that's the
only thing that
will really make us feel safe and secure
because
other than that it's just going to be
getting it and managing your your
symptoms and you know surviving it you
know
but one fun thing that i wanted to do is
uh i tweeted
i tweeted this out the other day and i
just wanted to talk about it on the
podcast and you know get you guys in the
comments
um talking about this on on your own
you know again also in the comments
and it was basically what
what real stupid thing did you believe
when you were a kid that you can't
believe like one of the ones i tweeted
about was
i used to think bathroom sink water was
the best water
like it was like spring water you know
like
i've been oh bathroom water tastes like
as if bathroom water tastes the best
and i really got some good ones from
people and i just want to read some of
them
um one guy's like jameis
jameis young i used to say miles per an
hour
this one guy was like i got tricked when
i was five years old for a few minutes
my cousin
she was five years older threw gold bond
powder on my chest and convinced me i
was gonna grow boobs and my thing was
gonna fall off
it was all in a 10 minute window but
i'll never forget it i can't believe i
fell for that
yeah some of these are like really good
my one buddy jason zuma wrote me said it
was obviously hose water
i remember that too like if you were
outside playing
playing hide and seek and all this kind
of stuff somebody got the water hole
the water hose out and you would drink
the water hose water oh
like somebody would have to hold it so
it wouldn't like squirt out too fast so
you'd have to bend it
yeah water hose water was a [ __ ] man
somebody said i thought post nasal drip
was a cereal
i thought the wwf was real yes
me too i thought the wwf was real up
until the point where
i'll never forget this it was like a
random saturday and i'm watching um
i'd never watched wrestling before and
then like they uh
they announced some guy comes out don't
i don't know who he is
and then they announce the champion hulk
hogan and i was like oh [ __ ] i'm
watching the title match
like i can't believe they just got a
title match on and nobody knows about
this
so i'm just watching and watching and
then like
hulk hogan comes out and then he's
losing and i'm like you know they start
fighting
and i was like oh my god am i gonna see
the champ lose the first time i watch
wrestling then he starts getting beat up
and then all of a sudden
hulk starts shaking and i was like oh my
god what is happening
and he's like waving his finger and he's
he's doing all this stuff and he
comes back and the guy hits him and he
doesn't do anything to him and he
you know hulk does the thing he body
slams him and he
hits him with the leg drop and it was
the most exciting thing
i'd ever seen in my life and i was
hooked
and then the next week the same [ __ ]
happened
and that's the moment i was like oh this
is fake
but for a week wrestling was the most
exciting thing i've ever seen in my life
let's see swallowing seeds would cause
food to grow in your stomach
oh yeah i don't even know if that's been
disproven i still believe that one
um what else this is one of my favorites
from billy griffin
no relation i thought kobe bryant
started kobe beef
like he just made up a new meat and
named it after himself
r.i.p to kobe bryant um let's see what's
another good one
i believe that when a lady has sex
during pregnancy she would add another
baby in the mix
boom twins
that my dad's gambling problem was an
opportunity for wealth
wow i think a lot of people had that one
that that was too morbid that would
sound too real
the first time my brother went to church
he asked my sister who the priest was
and she told him he was the smartest man
in the world
he's still in therapy this guy said this
girl said that that was from kate
um yeah there's a lot of good ones like
this there's just so many of them on
here
somebody agrees with me bathroom sink
water is the best of all tap waters i
believe this to this day
see thank you a lot of
you know i got a lot of like crazy ones
here um
that going to sleep wasn't fun the power
plant made all the clouds in the sky
i believe i i believed if i stepped on a
crack
i would in fact break my mama's back
this is one of my favorites too i said
sorry turtles whenever i walked over a
manhole because i thought the ninja
turtles were down there
you know so there's a lot of fun ones
like this so i would like for you guys
right in the comments right now just
write some of your favorites in the
comments like
so the you know the questions the
question remains is like
what stupid thing did you believe when
you were a kid
uh one of the ones like and a lot of
them they come from our parents like
one of the ones my mom told me was like
i always wanted to turn the light on
when she was driving
so uh one of the things that she would
tell me that
you can't turn the light on because you
could possibly get
shot if the lights were on like so
it was like up until my adulthood that i
was like i thought it was
that's why it was illegal like like i
thought it was illegal to have the light
on in the car while you were driving
and there's a possibility that somebody
might shoot you that was the reasons why
you wouldn't do it so
i mean that's just one of those that's
just one of those like come on mom
just be honest one of the this is one of
those ones too
my mom told me that there was like a bad
school
that you would send little kids and they
would have to live there
and you know it it was terrible they're
like oh like worst in prison
so if i was acting up she would get on
the phone and be like
i'm calling the bad school and then like
she would be on the phone talking like
yes uh his name is eric and he's been
really bad and i'm going to send him
and i'm sitting in front of her like no
hang up
i don't want to go to the bad school and
then you know she'd be like okay well
you better tell them you know what i
mean it's
god you know you look back at some of
the stuff that your parents did to you
like to like make you behave or some of
the things that they made you believe
it's like i don't know that [ __ ] is
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] is messed up you
know what i mean to this day
i thought if you smoked one cigarette
you were hooked for life
i don't know that one i don't know about
that one if that's not true or not or
that could be true for some people but
who knows
uh let's see i thought god and the bible
were the real deal
well there's another atheist right there
there's the atheist crowd
i used to think my dad was black because
he's darker than my mom
and that my mom was white and that's why
i was born a mix i can
[Laughter]
stupid anyways
there's a lot of dumb ones on there but
all right guys and here we are this is
now
a recorded uh i recorded a skype call
with some of my buddies
by the way it's the skype call it's over
the internet so it's a
the sound is a little wonky for you guys
listening just audio
uh you know when you look at the video
on youtube it's gonna probably look a
little
it gonna it's kind of probably gonna
come across better but it's still a good
listen
uh we're really good friends we're
making each other laugh we're just
talking about stuff and it's just
something to pass the time away so
right now here's uh you know three of my
good buddies uh we're the worst crew
ever
leonard robinson uh malcolm barrett and
mr craig
robinson enjoy all right guys um
thanks for coming back to uh skyping
with griffin and uh
this this uh time i have uh three of my
buddies on the line
uh three of them at one time
let me see if i got this right yeah
there they are leonard robinson
craig robinson and malcolm barrett no
relationship
with the work crew this is never
we've been doing social distancing for
10 years solid
never missed a day never missed a day
never see each other
don't stop but we're there when it
counts yeah
weddings funerals and maybe not
then too you just can't fail yeah we
yeah we
i don't know just don't ever count
so i see everybody's uh grizzly as hell
i was able to get a haircut because my
girl don't
she don't give a [ __ ] but like the rest
of y'all you cut everything
yeah i know i i i i was bored i just cut
it all out i wanted to
cut your hair i wanted to see what it
looked like i wanted to see what my
face looked like without a mustache for
the first time in like so long
and it's actually i don't know i don't
hate it no no no i went to
my haircut ladies down the street so she
just opened up just foreign
because i like getting my hair washed i
like all the other frills
barbers like don't do that [ __ ] so is
she
is she a salon is she a hairdresser yeah
why can't i call her a haircut lady
i got an apocalypse right man you got to
know how to apologize
i can see that are you like okay i know
leonard's married are you
somebody staying with you malcolm are
you like have you been by yourself
yeah man i got me a little i got me a uh
uh isolation bag
in there with you yeah we out here uh
you know eating lobster and and uh
having
white wine and just some doing it fancy
you know what i mean because i promised
myself i came up in the head man and i
promised myself i'm never going back you
know
i got a little butter
i got the butter unbelievable
just unbelievable i don't give as an
apocalypse or not man
every day how you been doing craig how's
life what's been going on with you
i'm good man just you know i gotta
figure out this workout situation
i've been eating again now i know man
you and me both i've been i've been
walking around the neighborhood though
but anytime i walk if you see anybody
you just feel like well here it is this
is where i'm gonna die
you know i mean so you just like six
feet [ __ ] hey uh
i saw i've been seeing your cooking
stuff man you've been getting down up in
there
you know what i did you know what i did
was i
ordered uh but mike i'm just gonna leave
mid
show he gonna walk up and leave this
[ __ ] that's gonna happen a few
times
maybe all of it no but i i got
one of the glue that holds this together
so i've ordered one of those like
you cook it yourself services because
it's actually very
inexpensive and they give you some
goodies it's called blue something
no not that one i got one called sun
basket but uh
that one's a good too blue apron's
another good one and it's actually very
affordable
because this one is like 10 11 a meal
and it serves two
so like i'll cook for myself and then if
my girl don't like the stuff i'll just
i'll have it for you know lunch and
dinner just to like you know cut down on
cost
because this i don't know i don't know
when we working again i know
craig got those mcdonald's ads i hear
all the time now i associate
you with mcdonald's
nuggets
good ass big mac wake up breakfast now
it's all about breakfast my campaign
oh okay yeah
yo i
wow you didn't recognize craig's voice
right away leonard damn i ride away man
i don't usually don't pay that much
attention to that commercial but then
there was something about the way he
said it i was like wait he really wants
that biscuit
well this is great now all of us are
just like leonard not working you know
what i mean so this is correct
we finally all on board with uh
uh i'm just kidding come on litter i'm
not taking the slander
i'm not taking the slander on on
on reply to okay uh i got a mcdonald's
spot coming out
i know you always gotta go on that
leonard always got a sneaky job going on
that you don't know to like you're
watching like csi
you know in the morning then he come out
on the screen like as the the beginning
police officer then is always working
in the can
every week after groundling in the words
of marshawn lynch you know
i'm i'm keeping uh i'm watching my
chicken man i get my
chicken straight i love eric because
erica will soaked you like today be like
hey you know your mama ain't [ __ ] i'm
just playing man
i have never said that ever but your
mama ain't [ __ ]
fantastic so are you guys um cause i'm
i'm just speaking for myself
i'm like you know my parents are out
here in uh oxnard
and i am concerned about them just
because of their age
i mean have you are you keeping up with
your parents or like are they in safe
places like
you know are you well what's their
situations like you know how's
everybody's parents doing
my people in chicago they good they
telling my my mom was in vegas but uh
like right before we went on
lockdown quote-unquote but um
but she got out of there and we was
worried about you know being on the
plane and stuff
right she's all right she's all right
they're good she's with my dad
that's good to hear are they
quarantining
and doing stuff like they feel like out
in the street
they not on the street in chicago i
think even has a curfew up to her oh
really
i think so i i you know so much
information coming at you
so fast yeah there's so much information
there's so much information coming from
so many different places too it's hard
to like
it's hard to keep it all together i wish
there was just like a like a webmd
like channel that that with doctors
giving it to us straight
all the time like this is what's going
on like what's happening yeah
or like a president who would say the
same thing each time
so that you would know yeah
you should do we gonna be in church by
easter baby
oh god
good luck i'm gonna get rid of this i'm
gonna get rid of this aids by memorial
day that's all i know
today was like uh you know he was
breaking it down how the testing is
going to go
and you know basically a year before
they have a vaccine
yeah i saw that too i saw that and i'm
glad that like i'm glad your parents are
in chicago because chicago's so spread
out but like
i would i i'm worried about i have some
family in new york and like new york is
so compact and like
everybody's on top of each other i'm not
surprised that it's spreading fast there
well i'll tell you this you asked me how
my family's doing i think my mom's okay
she's gonna she's gonna stay inside my
brother's gonna die
here's why my brother i called my
brother and i go um
hey how's it going man he's like you
know me man i gotta keep it moving i was
like you don't have to keep it moving
we're in the middle of it
literally just stay at home he's like
he's like you know i got to do my thing
i was like look i'll buy you a bunch of
groceries did you stay home don't go
nowhere
he's like i was like what do you want
he's like what's that stuff that's in
the can i was like i don't know what's
the name of this stuff he's like hold on
i was like what are you doing he was
like i'm going
to chat i was like where he was like at
the store i was like don't go to the
store
yeah i don't know what i'm doing stay in
the house yeah
i mean i did go to i did go to whole
foods the other day because i just
wanted to get some stuff
and it was like very like there's all
these lines to get in and then there's
like
lines at the checkout that with the with
the distancing they have like all the
stuff on the ground to make sure you
stay a certain way
from everybody but you know i'm going
i'm going a little stir crazy if you're
in my that's wrong i went to whole foods
i went to trader joe
and yeah they they got the uh the social
distancing chalk
out yeah yeah for the live view yeah
yeah
and i went to ralph's i went to uh
i wanted to go pick up some groceries a
friend a friend went through without the
store and ended up buying a bunch of
[ __ ] for us but we had to go grab it
and i went and checked my mail and just
took a little bit to drive man
and i felt [ __ ] amazing just sneaking
out the apartment for about
10 minutes yeah man just going to get go
every time i go get the mail i'm like oh
my god i'm free
you know what i mean it's just so it's a
weird feeling man it's a weird feeling
a weird deal i mean my folks are out in
phoenix
and uh they don't really have much of a
lockdown or anything going on but
just by just by nature are normally kind
of social
this anyways but so they will also just
hop in the car and just go you know to
like mcdonald's or something on a whim
but you don't need to do that
like yeah but it's okay i wash my hands
when i get home and
yeah my mom's gonna be home for about 12
hours straight and then
go right back out well i'm worried
because my mom my mom's got dementia so
she sort of understands because she's
like every day she's
you know telling me how bored she is but
my stepdad got the news on
so she could constantly see like stay
inside stay inside stay inside because
she wants to go out and go do
you know but go where she wants to go to
her grandmother's house who's been dead
for 50 years
you know what i mean so it's like it's
that kind of thing it's like a tough
and she thinks her grandma lives down
the street you know what i mean she
thinks her girlfriend goes down the
street
and uh she wants to go like oh i gotta
go see my grandma
it's funny my mom sent me an email
talking about
oh eric can you check on my grandmother
she's like i know i know she can be
difficult and stubborn and i'm looking
at just like
you talk about you you know what i mean
like she's describing herself talking
about her grandmother who's dead
so it's like i'm worried about that but
for right now she's safe
inside and i think she understands that
we can't go out but like another week
another two weeks it's like damn
does she does she at least skip the
boredom that way yeah do you know what i
mean
because it's not like oh i've been doing
the same thing every day no
this is scary because i think she wakes
up and hears oh we can't go out we can't
go out and then by the end of the day
she's like oh i'm bored so maybe she is
like
maybe it's groundhog day for her but i'm
just i'm wondering at what point
because i don't think we're going to be
out of this soon
and even if we are no our business
isn't going to start up right away what
we do is we're going to start up right
away maybe a production that's what i
was saying
the other day it's like even if the
president says we're back by easter
hollywood is not going to want to most
of hollywood's not going to want to show
up on set
knowing that this stuff is out because
most of hollywood you know kind of goes
to some real sources and tries to vet
the information a little bit better
they're not going to be forcing people
back into writing rooms or forcing
100 you know plus crew sets to be
working together
and then extra stuff you know yeah
they'll make work don't make extras work
they don't go to them
they were like look they were like these
these 100 have
the stuff so you got to just during that
move around
okay
that first large gathering though that
first large gambler people won't be like
i know yeah people gonna be looking
because i i'm not myself i've never been
a germaphobe
before but now i find myself like you
just everywhere you just thinking about
everything now just anytime you like you
know if you're ever
out you just see people like i don't
know if i want you know so i hope that
yeah i hope that
feeling goes away like how long is that
gonna like be in our consciousness what
do you guys think
my last spot comedy store was on
the 10th right before that
was like that guy and that microphone
took
my lift the [ __ ] out bro
i just i accidentally bumped my
microphone and i thought i had
everything
yeah yeah but we've been that's what huh
but that but that's been going on
forever
you know what i mean that that's right
you know what
i just i know but lose my
i hope i don't lose my connection to the
people you know what i mean
like the general popular being isolated
like this you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean i don't want
to forget to be
an every man i mean sometimes i'm the
kind of person that i stay
at home anyway you know what i mean i
find myself being at home sometimes you
know you get off the road you just
thought you just
you just don't want to be you don't you
don't want to do anything
but it's like damn like
yeah yeah but it's different when you're
forced to do it though
you know what i mean it's different when
they're like you can't go out
craig this is the most i've ever seen of
your apartment ever
did you move where are you at
well done yeah you still down the street
okay this is got no sense of orientation
right now
where did you move to a new spot
like you still on spring street i know
you're still at seven five five
[Laughter]
apartment seven b people with only under
the mat
people with ocd right now is going crazy
about craig's
to being open like that
look it smells like his cupboards are
just are you doing a costume change like
what are you doing right now in the
middle of a skype call
yeah hey loki
loki i feel like i had the coronavirus a
month ago oh
people were saying that people would
sound like they felt they
had some severe thing that i don't know
what it was
i was mad sick for like two weeks
straight like it wasn't just seven to
ten days you know
and i was like passing not that passing
out but like i was like the the fatigue
was crazy
and the cough was insane oh you probably
damn dude did you why didn't you go to
the hospital
i went to the doctor towards the end of
it and she said i was
you know everything whatever it is it's
leaving i guess
but she didn't see nothing out the
ordinary oh i feel but you know they're
saying that anyway they're saying if you
feel sick
stay home stay at home for 14 days and
see if you get over it so
maybe you didn't have it and now you're
over it i was lucky that i had like a
good
11 days off all right so i i still
you have to self-isolate when i was
feeling like i was going oh [ __ ] do you
guys know about michael yo right
michael joe had it and he was in the
hospital for a week
you know in the hospital yeah he was in
the hospital he was very ill and he's
just he's finally home right now i think
he's you know
right now recovering and taking it day
by day
was he on like ventilators and all that
stuff i didn't get the whole story i
told him
i asked him to come do a call with me
you know see if he wanted he wanted to
talk about it because
i it's just i want to hear what it's
like for some people because it seems to
be different for everybody
you hear about some people like you know
like kevin durant has it but is he fine
you know we haven't heard about tom
hanks like what's going on with tom
hanks
and why why did idris elba get tested if
he ain't have no uh
symptoms well a lot of people because
you've got well
people who are outside of the country
are able to get tested without having
symptoms
and so what's happening a lot of times
also with is with actors is
they're being on sets where someone
tested positive while they're out of the
country
so anyone who's getting in close con is
getting tested
the microphone
surround sound
[Laughter]
are we hearing some gurgling
i say end of july
oh that's a good yes i was thinking
maybe june
well i'm thinking about myself and like
what we do
so i'm thinking about like wait a minute
craig there's some kind of noise
i didn't make a noise that wasn't me yo
they're calling
is a coffee percolator running right now
do you have a fan blowing on you because
something
oh that might be the fad
this [ __ ] dude
no no there's something like there's
some
there's some noise it might be this
internal generator
yeah what does it sound like it sounds
like
it's not like like how are you are you
holding the phone
on the bed are you leaning it on
something
nope you holding it up because there's
some kind of
okay it's some kind of all right okay
there it went away
well it's still there well whatever this
is this is raw and unfiltered everybody
so raw enough filter hey
griffin i think it's july because
let's say june is when they go okay
let's open things up
i think it's going to take another month
and a half before we
actually go okay let's go to comedy
clubs before people go
oh let's go to let's open up movie sets
let's go to like
you know movie theaters and stuff like
that i don't think i think people are
going to be
red like so ready to go out and do
something
that i i mean it might be july but i
think people will be ready to like
so you think the moment they say
everything you're you're able to go
people are gonna be like flood out yeah
and when we go you
it's not gonna be enough work i mean
it's
it's not it's what am i trying to say
it's gonna be too much
work there's gonna be too many
opportunities well i don't know if like
i'm
i'm wondering if like the theaters and
arenas
if those are going to open up oh my god
i don't know what the [ __ ] that is it's
just
what craig just can you speak up
wherever you were before
okay all right right oh you had
something on [ __ ] you had
something on
[Laughter]
what were you making a smoothie do you
have a smoothie machine next to the bed
it's a cappuccino maker just left people
running
bingo parlor so i
i don't know if those places are going
to open up like is the nba going to be
like
all right all the seats are going to be
available are they going to be like
you know like when is it gonna be like
truly back to normal
i don't know if that's gonna be for
another year you know what would be
great
is if you could open stuff up but they
would still have some kind of
precautionary procedures in place
you know but um that's probably not
gonna happen but
what i'm thinking is even when you open
stuff up you still got people who
haven't been working a lot
you know so are they going to want to
you know are they going to want to drop
60 or 100
at the improv right right they're going
to want to drop 60 dollars at the ground
let's
go see a show you know you know maybe
this is going to be like i want to work
and try and save my money again or you
know get back out of debt you know i
don't know but
hold on hold on a second
you telling me it's 60 to watch a show
at the groundwork
he didn't find that way hold the [ __ ]
that means you ever watch the improv
show
oh my god oh
man look at you guys look at that look
at us look at that look at worse crew
back together again
you know what i could have walking dead
style and just as with diana's gonna be
improv sucks
no come on we've been to one of your
plays malcolm
oh
i came in with like a hat on i didn't
want you to see me so i could do a
i didn't go i didn't go my bad i'm not
been there at least twice
hey eric i like that time you weren't on
workaholics that was good
there was a lot of those those are my
favorite episodes
listen there's a lot of stuff we could
clown each other all day if we wanted to
all right there's a
there's a lot of ammunition on the
screen right now
there's a lot going on with this with
this crew
but hey legit though i think i think
production will come back sooner than
anything and they'll probably have
have you do something like you know get
a doctor's note or prove that you don't
have it or something like that
right have somebody set up to check your
temperature and you know
that's too much there's too much money
there's too much money on the line for
them to like
to stop too much money just show up they
was trying to show up
look i don't know if you noticed but up
until they shut stuff down
there was sending out notices on stuff i
was working on like
you know we got task force working on
this and we're
doing everything and blah blah and then
just after that you know i mean like
they
they are trying to squeeze the last bit
of money and not just us
our industry everybody everybody's gonna
be the last one
out of everybody and as soon as anyone
says you can go home
come home everybody's boss when you got
a job like we got it's gonna be like
come on home now the government said you
come here now
you know come here and do this work you
know but here's the thing here's the
thing i'm thinking about though
until they have a vaccine like
they're not gonna stop it so even if
they say april may
you can go back to work or whatever it's
still gonna be
people gonna be getting people gonna be
getting this
so like why why are they saying that
it's gonna i don't know why the
government is saying april
if they're not saying we're gonna have a
vaccine by april
what do you mean you don't know why you
know why well it's just
that money but but we're not
thank you malcolm but i just don't
it just it seems to me but are people
crazy like
i don't think people are stupid the more
information that comes in every day
everybody's at home watching the same
stuff
at a certain point are people gonna like
just be like oh okay
trump said it's okay so i'm gonna go to
the
whoa no i mean i think you will but i
think a lot of people will be like
no yeah i think so
yeah but at that point though at that
point
you know if people are staying home like
right now where i live the
people are trying to help people out
they said they're going to lower some of
the rent for
help you for two months right but like
when the government if the government
says
no everybody back to work there's still
people that are not gonna be able to go
to work
and then what's gonna happen and if they
if something happens to them like they
get fired from that's all lawsuits right
there okay
how are you going for somebody go to
work and it's a goddamn deadly virus
going around i know that's what i'm
saying it's like i don't know it's like
you saw that thing that three million
people applied for uh
unemployment it's 100.3 three something
million people and it's like the highest
has ever been before that was like six
hundred thousand
so for nationwide i don't know
california
yeah i mean i'm sure so many people
and i'm wearing all these homeless out
here too and then trying to put them in
shelters and i saw a guy on the news the
homeless guy was saying
i'd rather be outside i don't want to be
cooped up in a shelter with
people that might have it you know what
i mean and they like i don't know
hotels for them oh that's what they're
trying to do yeah
that works that makes sense
i tell you this what's crazy is the seat
is staggered because it's like
my my renters my landlord or whatever
they just sent a letter saying like
they will give you uh a hundred dollars
if you uh send your rent
uh in by like the fourth or something
like that so they're trying to give you
a hundred dollars
just for this month they'll give you one
hundred dollars if you send
well they know they can't collect and
it's also stupid because it's like if i
can't pay my rent it's not because i'm
short one hundred dollars like i
paid my rent the same thing oh you
helping us out with a hundred dollars oh
thank you what about this other
thousands
it's like oh i always think yeah
people lost a job and it's only a
hundred dollars they lost
look if i was there for a hundred
dollars short on
rent i was really like three thousand
dollars short on that
yeah it's not it's not like you
compartmentalizing your money
i like our lenders exactly i like how
your your screen was frozen on a good
face that was your
face no i know what you mean it doesn't
make it don't make any sense it doesn't
make any sense you know it's like it's
not like we have our money but you know
what i was talking to somebody else
about this too is that
like for our industry like let's say
you're just a comedian i know a bunch of
comedians who were
making good money like per gig
but they were working gig to gig and
they got a lot of expenses
you know they got like a thousand dollar
car payment they got a
5 000 rent or something and they were
making enough money to cover that
because of all the gigs they had going
on
but all that [ __ ] stopped i mean there's
a lot of people that have been living
beyond their means and now they're in
trouble
so that's the other thing is like
especially in our business like
travel is how a lot of folks make their
money you know i mean you make your your
money from gigs like
musicians are making you know less money
from you know making more money from
touring than from album sales and stuff
like well at least like at least like uh
somebody at least
at least with music though you don't
necessarily need an
audience to to play i mean i'm i'd be
nice if some bands were like live
streaming like you know hey i'm gonna be
streaming you know
i mean if they were inclined to get
together you know it just depends on the
age group
you know what i mean it's been so
beautiful yeah beautiful like
people been doing the zoom thing like
this uh philharmonic orchestra
did the thing i said it to you uh the
lady uh
uh angela merkel and they did in germany
they're giving the artist money you know
they set up a fund for the artist it's
dope
hey but what what's this gonna do for me
and greets yo i know well
they're gone meet and greets are gone
we're gonna be meet greet like that i
did when i was in chattanooga
it was the friday before everything went
crazy i said to them okay thanks for
coming to the show uh we're not doing no
pictures
like thanks for coming out
and i jetted out you know what i mean
we're
charging for the meet and greet no i
don't charge we're like
we we do an extra charge but i guess
it's coming off now
look how guilty he's sounding about that
i'm not
[ __ ] i was saying one of the sweetest
hustles i saw was uh
rodney perry um had a meet and greet
after and he had that
he had that system down like you go up
shake his hand
you take a picture and by the time he
got off stage somebody was printing that
photo out
taking your twenty dollars wow so yeah
he was making money i think he was
making money over that that he was off
the gig
all right well i get any time people are
doing that that's usually the case
it's yeah and it's and it's it's also
demanding venue
do you know what i mean like because i'm
one of those people where it's just like
depending on the demand and the venue
it's like you're like the meet and
greets is going crazy in another place
like don't nobody know what [ __ ] you are
you know what i mean yeah
on the internet like like on like
instagram somebody will send me a
message
and then they'll say something like oh
man i'm sure you'll probably never see
this
and i'm like yeah you think you're the
only one sending me a message
like a thousand messages like [ __ ]
thank you
so it's like you know what i i feel like
i feel like a new entertainer hustle
cameo because i'm all on camera
before because before i feel like cats
was
turning their nose up at it but now it's
an easy way to like i don't have to be
nowhere are you going to pay me that
same
okay they asked me to lower they're
asking everybody to lower their price on
cameo so people so because people
whatever the reason was i was like okay
fine i lowered it down or whatever it
was
but like i used to get mad at cameo
because they would tell people
they would tell comics and actors like
oh eric griffin's on this and
these people would call me and be like
yo tell me about cameo and i'm like
let me explain something to you i'm
montez from workaholics okay
that's a weird specific thing so if
you're a workaholics fan
you're gonna be like oh [ __ ] that's the
guy that you know
it's if you're not something like that
and you're not touring regularly nobody
give a [ __ ] about you you know what i
mean some of these people that wanted to
be on cameo
nobody give up
but you look like craig you would kill
on cameo craig but it's like
how many videos you think you do in a
week cameo a month week a month
well before i kept raising the price so
i wouldn't have to do it
i was pricing myself out you know what i
mean but it would be like one
at the height of it it would be like two
a week
yeah this is probably the time to do it
but i'm saying you specifically craig
would make a lot of money on cameo i
don't know if you're on there
i'm not they hit me up all the time oh
but before you do let me give you that
referral link
let me give you this referral link let
me get you one because now because
people would love that it's gonna be a
lot of people that's gonna be like
i want they're going to be like and then
it'll be like oh
the office was my favorite show can you
say happy birthday to my brother you're
his favorite character
that's what it needs to be something
like that some people on there i just go
why would you know why would anybody
gonna be just like brian's hello friend
are you all cam you're malcolm no i'm
not on camera it's too much work
how much you charge here it's not it's
not that much work i'm at
right right now it's down to 60 but i
had it at 99
no i was making a lot of money i pissed
on 99
oh how much would yours be
i don't know i don't know
i'm sure i'm sure oh yeah
how do you decide what what the price is
it's up to you man
i started at i started at a lower way
lower price because i didn't know what
this even was
and then as they started to come in i
was like no no let me do 20. let me do
30. let me do 40. let me do 50 you know
because people like
hey it's a it's actually a very it's
actually a nice gift
you know if you started like 15 yeah i
started at 15
and let me tell you the funny thing my
one of my my agent one of my old agents
he bought one and he wanted me to say
that
he was my best agent i ever had so
so i said of all the agents i fired
you were the best
he was yeah
hilarious but this is going to be the
thing people are going to be streaming
and gaming
wait so when they ask you to lower the
price like how did they what did they
say
she just texted me and said okay can you
lower the price because
a lot of people like you know this is
good a good people
want to buy these kind of things to stay
connected and they might be sending this
as a gift to somebody and
you know we people are struggling right
now you know the whole rig of a role and
i was like fine i don't care it's an
extra anyway
dude it cost me nothing
like 10 seconds of somebody's like hey
can you say happy birthday to my brother
then i just go
hey what's up john happy birthday you
know white folks loves movies i say
whatever the thing they want me to say
from the show
and then that's the end of it they're
gonna get a lot they're gonna have
they're gonna make you be like
can you like say the guy's name but then
look directly at the camera like you do
in the office you know it's gonna be
that kind of [ __ ]
can you deadpan my brother you know
you're gonna be making like all this
money just doing this
cause you're dead
uh crew ever we gonna buy that greg can
you deadpan
we're going to be buying cameos just to
get each other to show up like hey man
can you just like show up
listen to this quarantine
i'm going to every one of leonard's
shows
okay okay hey
what we're going to land are we going to
do let's do we're going to do like a you
know how they had that bite that big
bicycle thing and you go bar hopping
for us we're gonna go to we're gonna go
to malcolm's play
then we're gonna put malcolm here we're
gonna go to leonard's show then we gonna
go to
craig i don't know what craig's gonna be
doing he's gonna be playing music
hey man better open up the improv you
gonna be driving that [ __ ]
i know man who you telling i'm gonna be
doing uber
i'm gonna be doing uber people like
montez
hell yeah then i'm gonna be and i'm
gonna be streaming in there too like
doing my
doing my podcast with my uh with my
with my uber drive uber people
how would i come out she's on our
podcast today uh
she's going to whole foods oh i just got
a i got three stars from sierra now what
a [ __ ]
i don't actually watch that [ __ ] damn
dude i don't even you know what i didn't
know by the way speaking of i didn't
know that
we also were raided on uber until
i opened the app and i saw this number
and i was like
what is this number right here and they
and they were
ranking us i was like well damn that
made me like change my tune
what's your uber number what's your uber
number i think i'm like let me look at i
think i might end up i'm like four or
six or something like that
can they can they see what you write
down and then
rate you i think they wait until they
see if you can get a tip or not i think
that's what that is
i don't think i don't think well i rate
well yeah me too
me too ever ever since that [ __ ] nobody
gets five
everybody five for me yeah you gotta be
a dude like one time somebody was like
hey um i can't go there can i just drop
you off and i was like
in the middle of the street i'm a 4-7
i'm like well
it's like like we're gonna have to wait
for another uber for them or something
he's like no i'll drive i'm like
okay uh i beat you dude i got in one
i got in one and the dude had loud
religious music playing okay
but not like not like you know this
little light of mine no no
it was like a live recording of like
a church and and they were like you know
it was like
jesus here's your lord jesus is your
lord and it just kept going and going to
go and i was like
like i don't want that or rap music
playing or any kind of music playing at
that decibel in in my uh
lift yeah so i gave that guy
individuals at the church yeah it was
like that it was crazy
and they switch it to like rap music
yeah
oh yeah all the time yeah they do that
everywhere oh
yeah yeah but but it's the difference
between like the suv the uber black
and like just like you know regular
because
a lot of times i'll take the suv you
know and then and i get used to them
being like just
catch finding me wherever i'm at boy you
get that regular one they'd be like look
i'm on this corner man
yeah i know hurry up
yeah yeah
a notification like your dude's about to
leave you know right
you got five minutes i'm in the drive
picking up my order
i know but is it like okay but do you
ever get in the car
and it's a white guy
and the white guy turns on the rap music
that always makes me feel i represent
usually uh
i've never heard them yeah i have never
heard them change the music every time i
step in it's already
it's already on like little it would be
or something like
like that i had a situation one time
what about my i was like what about my
profile makes you think i want to hear
little uzi burst yeah man
i'm gonna get him over with a white guy
an indian guy to try these guys see what
happened
yeah you're gonna check it out that's
not like it's the beginning of a joke
i'm
my worst ever experience was i got into
a lift
and this black woman she's looking at me
and she really she was acting weird but
she said
she goes you look like mr potato head
oh wait five tall but here's the thing
though but this is the thing though
i don't want to tip that one wait she
didn't even laugh though
she didn't laugh she didn't like i'm
just kidding
nothing she was like you know you look
like mrs potato head and i was like okay
okay so and we just dropped
you know we just driving so i was like
okay you know and i like to sit in the
front
i don't want to sit in the back of a
jetta you know if it's a jetta or a
corolla
or whatever if it's regular uber i'm
sitting in the front i'm not just saying
a limo you know what i'm saying
so i'm sitting in the front so i'm just
trying to turn away from her but i
tweeted that lift i was like yo
you know this chick she she's talking
about me
she just roasted you upon arrival yeah
just like get in the car
you know you look familiar you look but
this they
you look familiar you look like like
like if mr potato head is a real dude
you know what i mean like
38 like you know you look like there's a
potato here though
yeah man [ __ ] pissed me off all right
hey this one dude asked me was i e40
ah
oh
i feel like we all doing auditions
everybody's doing auditions for the
walking dead or whatever whatever
apocalypse show is about to come out
we're all doing auditions for right now
world war ii
did you did are they making a two to
that i didn't like that what shows are
you guys watching by the way
to finish i saw exactly
it was it was cool but have you seen
romney
yes no i know it's oh and like i think
you got the emmy and all that
yeah god damn that's good it's a good
show man it's worth watching you guys
should watch it it's a great show
it's on hulu i had him on the podcast
too
good i just
he did the damn thing on that yeah man
that's good
yeah i like i like romney i watched uh i
watched the purge on usa network that's
also on hulu
they made a series that before yeah yeah
i've been
i've been benjamin yeah so i'm trying to
i'm trying to
i know ozarks is coming back i can't
wait for that
i fell off for ozarks like the first
really you didn't like the second season
i i
i think i i mean i don't know i just i
fell out
i want to get back into it because i see
you know all this
crazy stuff reading about but um
lately i just been watching rick and
morty
there's a lot of things together i mean
there's just i'm i can't
i'm waiting to find that like show
that's like oh i can really
delve into this for like a week but i
haven't found one of those
have you guys ever gone on netflix and
seen you go to the show section like the
tv shows
and i'm like damn there's a lot of shows
on netflix like
new like 2020 2019 there's so many shows
yo netflix is like going to blockbuster
now like when i'm
now it's like it's that thing where i
look through a bunch of things and i go
no i know it's like
going netflix is like going to jerry's
deli or the cheesecake factory yeah man
that menu is too big
it's too big thank you thanks for taking
it to food craig i like that
you okay the tiger king is kind of crazy
if you watch it what you gotta watch for
is the
the lady giving clues that she actually
did kill her husband
she's smooth as hell and it's like but
and it's crazy it's it's a
it's it's a hard watch to get into but
if you like stick with it it's
it's ridiculous and it's like
unbelievable
but um did you guys see don't [ __ ] with
me but you gotta watch the lady because
she's accused of killing her husband it
never came to nothing
and she's not in jail and this other
dude you know but uh
she it she'd be telling on herself like
literally oh you guys
and it's like you got over there i'm
gonna call you later you tell me what
the clues are i just watched it but
i just felt like she was guilty but yeah
i need to hear the hard evidence that
you said she already dropped in there
you know it was it was three specific
things y'all are y'all gonna watch
yeah i'm gonna watch all right i'm gonna
watch don't tell me because everybody's
telling me to watch this no we do we'll
let's all watch
it let's all watch it and we'll get back
on another call in a week and we'll talk
about
tiger king we'll do a musical not not
lion king tiger king
tiger king i killed that mother have you
guys seen it
did you did you see don't [ __ ] with cats
i am so exotic
what about the aaron hernandez
documentary did you see that i saw one
of them
but it's a gabriel hernandez supposed to
be some check out
well what's that one the the something
of gaming
huh the comedian
oh it must be they all the same right
that was
[Laughter]
album coming out then it's fire oh my
god
this crew is full of monsters all
monsters
all right guys this has been good um i
thank you guys for coming on
um these are my good buddies here this
is leonard robinson craig robinson
malcolm barrett uh i appreciate you guys
coming on i want you guys to stay safe
you know stay healthy uh much love to
all you guys and your families
and uh you know let's do this again soon
you know let's
think of something specific to talk
about you know we'll watch some shows
because
just review these shows and like stay
caught up you know and let's stay
connected too guys you know
i know we don't we joke about we joke
about being the worst crew but we are
the worst crew
so they connected worse
through emma we are the worst coach so
let's let's change that [ __ ] you know
what i mean
so hey thanks for having us bro i love
yeah man don't leave yet guys don't
leave you hold on a second
all right guys that was uh my my crew
there and uh
i hope you enjoyed it uh i got some
other great calls coming in i got andrew
santino coming in i got kalila scheduled
i got jeremiah watkins i got i'm gonna
try to talk to a lot of the guys that
i've already that i've had on my podcast
i'm gonna check in with them and see how
they're going and some new people we'll
see who
who also shows up uh to come do a call
with me but
i appreciate you guys listening and you
know i'll see you
on friday i'm doing again fridays i'm
gonna start doing the quarantine i'm
doing some i'm going live so get your
send your questions in you can send your
questions to me at eric
eric griffin.com or you can hit me up on
instagram send me those messages
you know towards the middle of the week
i'll put up one of those instagram um
story things where you can ask the
question there or you can send me an
email like i said and you know twitter
wherever you can get a hold of me
send me messages for questions that you
want me to to answer or just things you
want to talk about
all right i appreciate you guys as
always
and i will see you next week
you